نقلت صحيفه ادعوت ت احرونوت عن مصادر
اسرائيليه ان حركه حماس متشدده في مواقفها
وتطرح مطالب منفصله عن الواقع كما وصفتها
وقالت تلك المصادر للصحيفه ان حماس تصر
على وقف دائما لاطلاق النار وبانها غير
مستعده للعوده الى وقف مؤقت لاطلاق النار
رغم استعداد اسرائيل للنظر في هدنه طويله
ما بين اسبوع اللا اسبوعين واجراء تغييرات
في الترتيبات العسكريه في قطاع غزه
واضافت الصحيفه الاسرائيليه ان التقديرات
في اسرائيل تشير الى ان صفقه جديده بشان
الرهائن لن تنضج قبل الاسبوع الاول من
يناير المقبل رغم استعداد اسرائيل لمواصله
المفاوضات على مدار الساعه للتوصل الى
اتفاق على حد قولها
واوضحت الصحيفه ان المفاوضات تركز على
اطلاق سراح ما يصل الى 40 رهينه بما في
ذلك النساء والتقديرات انهن ست او سبع
نساء اضافه الى عشرا الرهائن من كبار السن
والمرضى والمصابين ومن يعانون من اضطرابات
ال نفسيه في حين تطالب حماس باطلاق سراح
معتقلين بارزين بينهم من سمتهم الصحيفه
بالقتله اديع تحرت نقلت عن مصر امني ان من
المتوقع عقد اجتماع اخر لفرق التفاوض في
الايام المقبله وحينها سيعرف فيما اذا كان
هناك من يمكن الحديث
معه